I'm gonna ask you to make a copy of this
diagram in a second okay but before you
do it I want to show you something is
gonna be slightly slightly different
this is the copy this is what I want it
to look like
what's the difference look carefully
better okay good so you can see all I've
added in and you can start drawing now
make on a new piece of paper on your
page say diagram you could do another
what if you can fill it same say bits
and pieces here okay but what I'd like
you to do is add these squares up the
top okay now you've added those as you
are I'm drawing that in I want us the
question when we drew this diagram
before it was about conversions you can
see that at the top right but what are
we converting between what kinds of um
what kinds of things we'll be measuring
with all of these different kinds of
Units all of these are units for one
kind of thing you measure up why do we
measure it starts of an hour length very
good right so it's it's one-dimensional
do you recall one dimensional but you
also should remember on the other side
this piece of paper I think there was
that table that said well one
dimensional measurements of lengths
they're not the only kinds of things
around so when you redraw this diagram
but with the squares on it this is no
longer about length conversions this is
about anyone think they can guess what
its jam area conversions thank you area
okay so this is what's going on okay now
I could just tell you what's going on do
yeah you can I could just give you the
answers like the numbers and on arrows
in a lot kind of you but I want you to
think a little more about what's
happening here okay so here's what I've
like uh up on the if you got a bit of
space of somewhere around your diagram
okay what I want you to do is draw a
square centimeter okay if you can make
it like actually one square centimeter
okay so I've zoomed in a bit which is
why - so large now
help me remember how
many millimeters Ave in a regular
centimeter yeah this 10 right so from
Center which is a hundred of them in a
meter to millimeters which is a thousand
of the minamino so that's why there's a
difference of ten here's my square
centimeter right my square centimeter
maybe you want to label it as such so I
now want to think about and to yell out
the answer just yet I want to think
about well how many square millimeters
are there in this square centimeter now
we know there are ten millimeters in
every centimeter right so this square
centimeter is one centimeter across the
top like that and it's also one
centimeter along the side like that's
the way you actually drew this shape
yeah so now if I were to think about
wait a second how many square
millimeters fit into this I'm gonna have
to divide up and think about well he
often the side here that's like my
square millimeter I should move him out
of the way because that arrow is
pointing in him he's my very very tiny
square millimeter okay so how many of
these guys can fit inside my square
centimeter hmm now the answer is a
hundred how I see that okay let's add on
to our square centimeter I want you to
divide it firstly I'm gonna divide it
vertically like this so I'm gonna do the
best as IQ
okay so there's five millimeters that
way and another five millimeters this
way better okay my scales not pair
because I haven't actually used a ruler
so I'm gonna cheat a little bit
let's leave those guys out okay so you
can see if I had placed or if you in
place your one centimeter across here
you've got your markings for every
melamine and you've got ten of them
right so that's across the top but in
the same way you've got across the side
another set of ten divisions okay so
you're gonna have to draw these ten
lines but draw them horizontally now I'm
just gonna be a bit sneaky and do this
okay
so sorry you can't quite do that but you
can see what's going on right you can
see how a hundred is pretty easy to fit
into you cuz he sware millimeters this
so so tiny okay you're gonna fit ten
across this way ten across this way so
that's why there's a hundred of them in
it 100
okay so now I'm going to zoom back out
as you finish your diagram okay and it's
okay you'll have you'll have time to
finish this off I just went from a
square centimeter to a square millimeter
right so if you think back to what we
did with like convergence right if
you're converting to a smaller unit
they're little so you need lots and lots
of them so am I gonna multiply or divide
I'm gonna multiply all right Beth did
you order you don't need to write it
again because it will be exactly the
same because just like no I mean as a
small square meal is also small so you
don't need to replicate that part so I'm
gonna say I want to multiply now rather
than say multiply by a hundred which is
true the reason I multiply by 100 is I
multiply by come back to my diagram over
here I multiply by 10 this way and I
have to multiply by 10 this way as well
there's two dimensions remember so I'm
actually going to say this is multiplied
by a term squared okay
it's the same number but what I'm trying
to indicate to you is like why is it 100
it's not 100 randomly it's because 10
times 10 which helps you also see the
pattern of if you went this way okay so
here's my meter so if I had a meeting
this way and a meter this way
if I went from a square meter this
thing's pretty big yeah how many square
centimeters am I going to fit in a
hundred square hundred this way and a
hundred this way so I'm going to
multiply by a hundred squared by the way
that's 10,000 right this is where that
hectare idea comes from okay yeah this
guy that yes is a hundred times one
hundred a thousand ten thousand isn't it
ten thousand four zeros whereas this is
a hundred make sense okay one more if
you had a square core man up which is
really really big
how many square meters there be in there
think look at the pattern yeah they go
yeah very good times a thousand excuse
me
squared that's a million that's a lot
that's because the square meter might be
big
he's a meet-up that is big but it's
great kilometer so that's why this
number gets so much bigger okay so this
is going from all the big units all the
way down to the small ones I need to
finish this I've only done half of it
right what's gonna go on the top yeah
yeah division going in the other
direction right if I'm going from middle
units to big ones so all of these are
going to be division
okay
okay now we're not doing it today but I
just wonder some of you want to think
about see how I did this to work out
what's going on from a square set of
eight up to square millimeters I wonder
what you would think don't shout it out
just think about it we'll look at it
later
I wonder what you would think if we
weren't doing length or area but what if
we were talking about volume right what
if we were trying to now I think some
people can work it out we will have a
look at it later but I just want you to
think like how is the pattern gonna be
similar yeah how is it going to be
different okay so it's just something
for you to be having Iggy's - oh yeah
dude the dude that's meant to be thank
you square pepper which is of course
still a million